good evening and welcome tonight
Americans taken hostage many still
missing it was five years ago this
summer that Isis began to execute a
series of young Americans who had been
taken hostage journalists and aid
workers who had gone to Syria their
plight revealed the frustration and
anger of the American hostage families
who accused the FBI and the White House
under the Obama administration of not
doing enough to help and in fact often
blocking efforts the families were
making to get their loved ones freedom
the first of the Americans to be
executed by Isis was photo journalist
James Foley and since then his parents
have been outspoken in their criticism
of how they were treated by the US
government
the squeek Foley's parents who have
created the James Foley Legacy
Foundation are out with a new report on
us hostage policy and we're joined
tonight by Diane Foley to talk about all
this Diane thank you so much for joining
us you went through such frustration
from the government is it any better now
yes we're very happy to report that
things are better for Americans who are
considered hostage that is Americans who
are held by terrorists criminal gangs or
pirate 50 well we also found out that
Americans who are unlawfully detained by
foreign governments on the other hand
are sorely in need of similar similar
interagency effort to bring them home
that was meaning people like Robert left
like in Saudi Arabia there's a doctor
well lead a tight
Venezuela for May but now in Iran
Princeton graduate student way so there
are hundred unlawfully detained American
by foreign government or are in need of
a similar interagency effort and support
by the highest levels of government and
Diane as you know and as you said a
number of Americans taken hostage over
the last few years
among the missing journalists often ties
taken in Syria and as you said former
FBI agent Robert Levinson last seen in
Iran who issued this chilling plea to
the US government on video please help
me 33 years of service to the United
States is something Diane Foley just how
many Americans are there who remain
hostages overseas you know the actual
numbers are classified and we are trying
to get more accurate numbers but we
definitely estimate hundreds of
Americans are taken hostage and or
unlawfully detained every year abroad
you say hundreds of them really hundreds
hundreds Brian many many we are on top
reported because often they feel the
best way to get people home is keep the
case very quiet but at times that
benefit captors and doesn't get the
attention of the highest levels of our
cup and Diane on that point a question
for you from our control room from
executive producer Rhonda Schwartz
Rhonda Dianne hostage families are often
told to keep quiet not to tell the
public not to tell anyone what's going
on what's your thoughts on that having
been through all this every situation is
very unique and it really depends on the
family because it is true that a lot of
media coverage can increase the value of
so one has to take that into account it
also can help find the person and find
people who might be able to help them
come home so it's a very personal choice
and often depends on the strategy of how
they're going he brought home Diane are
you left feeling that if the government
had done more your son could have
brought home oh definitely Brian I I
feel that we did not engage as a
government because of the civil war in
Syria and therefore we missed out on a
lot of intelligence about Isis that we
would have known had we engaged with the
captors of the four Americans so I do
feel they could have turned out
differently if our government had
dissociated with them the standard US
policy is that Americans don't pay
ransom to get hostages released from
terrorists that was the case they told
you in fact they actually threatened you
with prosecution if you tried to raise
the money on your own is that policy you
think correct well there is no research
that shows that not paying ransom brings
people home it actually the opposite
Americans and the British because of
that policy have worse outcomes however
I feel there's many ways to negotiate
ransoms only one there are sanctions
there are other things that captors want
I think the key issue is the need to
engage with captors when our citizens
are at risk and finally let me ask you
how do you rate what grade do you give
to the Trump administration on this
issue I have to commend the Trump
administration
yeah Trump administration has made the
return of Americans more of a priority
without a doubt and as a matter of fact
I'm hoping as Secretary Pompeo and the
president bode 20 they will remember
these innocent Americans such as dr.
walid Baha'i Princeton graduate student
Wang the Venezuelan executives who are
held hostage there as well as in Syria
Mudge Kamala's is that's just the tip of
the iceberg there are so many
other Americans and in need of US
leadership and absolutely
Diane Foley thank you so much for
joining us